i ask you a simple question
and i would like for you just to answer
simply
uh is it does it make sense for the
leaders of the free world to go in
to talk to and see what's going on at
the border i am the secretary of
homeland security and it is my
responsibility
to manage the border at the direction of
the president and the vice president
and i have visited the border on
multiple occasions the vice president
served as the attorney general of a
border state
of california and she is quite familiar
uh with the situation on the border
she's laughing
well there's a heating exchange between
congressman ralph norman and dhs
secretary
mayorkas over the butt administration's
handling of the border crisis
this as 56 house republicans urged the
president
to remove vice president harris from her
role leading the immigration
crisis south carolina congressman ralph
norman is one of those republicans
calling for her removal and he joins us
now welcome congressman
rachel you've called for her removal do
you think it's going to happen it sounds
like she
might want to give up this role anyway
she doesn't seem to like it
well they're running out of people
rachel i don't know i mean if all she
can do is laugh which is what she's done
about going to the border then she
should be removed now i don't know who
they would have in her place
this administration continues to baffle
me on
the people in charge including marcus
and and particularly
the vice president you know for her to
say
in guatemala that not to come i mean who
is she moses
uh on the mountaintop saying not come
and think that we're going
that it has any meaning or merit it
doesn't that that's the whole point of
going to the border congressman is that
you can say the borders close but if
you're down there and you see that it
isn't
it might change your policy prescription
are you satisfied that even if a visit
from her would do that
or ideologically are they too invested
in their own narrative at this point
well the actions speak louder than uh
than their words no
they're not going to do anything i mean
that's why they're taking the position
that they are
my first question to marcus was have you
ever had a medical
physical and his response was he was
insulted i said i'm not asking about
what they found i'm just saying have you
had a physical
in the physical you literally go into
the office you ask questions you meet
him face to face
and he uh and i said what's the
difference with
going to the border particularly when it
affects america in the way this is
it's affecting it and you know his words
were studying
the wall what's there to study you're
not building i saw the steel on the
ground
i saw the post up you're not building it
well we're investing in technology
really uh how good technology is going
to be when you have a million and a half
americans
million and a half illegal immigrants
already in america what's the
technological
technology going to chase them down no
and
we have a saying in the south don't spit
in my face and tell me it's raining
and that's what this administration
continues to do and we're going to call
them out on it
you know congressman if i neglected to
go get my physical there would be a
reason there would be a reason i
wouldn't go the doctor i believe there's
nothing wrong with myself or i don't
believe the doctors there'd be some
reason or maybe i'm just lazy
that i wouldn't go to get the physical
in your estimation it's clear i think
any sober-minded person would look at
this and say
it's clear they're not addressing the
border crisis in any responsible fashion
that leads to the question of why
why aren't they willing to get the
physical why aren't they willing to
address the border crisis
at its cause well they don't want the
media attention
they think the americans will give them
a pass on it
when we went we wouldn't they wouldn't
allow us to take pictures they had buses
that were literally hauling the children
out to
god knows where so we couldn't see the
the cages they were in
and uh it's it's really an insult of
what they're doing and
once they're in the country uh that's it
and their
their end game uh is to get them
registered to vote get them a driver's
license
and then put them on the uh the public
dole and
have voters i that's the only thing that
you can really
assume that they're doing because it
means vote to them
votes to them and they think that's a
put them in a permanent position
to win elections i think you're
absolutely right i mean when you when
you go to the question of why
i think you've hit the nail on the head
that's exactly why they're doing it
that's exactly why they won't change
their policy whether she goes there or
not
last week i believe on laura ingram's
show raymond arroyo had a very
interesting
um investigative report on the border
where you know law enforcement and the
mayors um in
at the border were saying we feel like
we're helping
the cartels so they're bringing the
people across
and we just take them and and do the
next part of the job which is just
moving them on
out onto you know as you said all across
the country i mean
we're actually doing we're forcing our
law enforcement
to do the work of the cartel this is
like insanity
it is insanity racial and if you talk to
the border patrol agents
uh you know what they're doing they're
changing diapers they're not doing what
they were trained to do
and that's why at least they visit even
if you're not going to do anything
would would highlight the problems and
maybe
i doubt it but maybe it would give them
some emphasis to
to do stop this insanity because once
they're in the country they're in the
country and
that we're not going to get them out and
they're going to be on the
our school systems our hospitals you
name it in public and
we just can't put up with that or try to
do what we can to highlight it
it's happening right now representative
ralph norman thank you so much for doing
what you can and for being on the
program appreciate it